ooh I'm Ram right can't do it there
can't easily letter and absolutely
correct
I read right am I supposed to be
whipping up a and Owen Wilson impression
really really MediaWiki could be C
good-looking can't do it Wow Wow I'm
Jerry we're gonna watch you Andrew
vigil trailer number one here we go
I am mediocre ly excited I'm excited I
love Zoolander lenders like a classic he
was once the world's most famous male
model even his looks were household
names
leti gray Magnum and of course loose
tablet but that was a long long long
time ago old LeMay there's still snow
joke up there miss fashions change meet
the biggest supermom the whole world is
all that better to cover female mom
oh is old I think he's asking do you
have a hot dog or a bum Derek Zoolander
I'm with Interpol I need to hell if you
showers I trust her
someone's trying to kill the old move ah
world all of them died with your
signature look
this is Bruce steel right we need you to
infiltrate the wall of high fashion back
ashore to Landers right now
[Music]
you would amaizing
I'm sorry I can't understand a word that
you're saying Oh Derek go spend enough
you've got it
[Music]
yeah
yeah
oh I recognize criminal mastermind who
could be behind this where's my goddamn
latte but how am I supposed to start
with God - by the balm of Agathe I'm a
pirate Gaga you're Derek Zoolander stop
the Chaney's throwing stuff with a look
planche me that beautiful neck wait
Magnum now maybe we could try Wasco wait
who directed that
Stiller anyway yeah that looks like a
funny movie and it looks like if you
liked
Zoolander you will like this one seeing
a trailer like that I'm old yeah I'm
gonna remain a little cautious about
this one but I could easily see how the
trailer for this movie would make it
look a lot more dumb in the wrong way
than the movie is gonna be I feel like
Ben Stiller's comedies that he directs I
like the comedies that he directs you
know Tropic Thunder was fantastic I
thought Cable Guy was underrate Lord
ahead of its time like people were not
ready for such a dark comedy especially
with Jim Carrey but it seems like that
they're honoring you know what we loved
about Zoolander however I have my
concerns after films like anchorman 2
which was like okay and then you got
Dumb and Dumber - which was just so bad
it's hard to follow up a comedy after so
long because one of my complaints that I
feel when I see like that's been 14
years so over decades gone by I don't
feel like the characters are different
at all yeah it's like not that I want
them to be completely different but it's
like they seem like they're exactly the
same characters yeah and that was kind
of my problem with dummy number 2 like
oh my god how are they exactly the same
well it's also hard to because it's like
at the time in which new liner came out
at least for a lot of people our age
that was when you learn
the names Ben Stiller and Owen will ya
Will Ferrell's so like you've already
got that sort of freshness working
against you were like how do we approach
this cuz it isn't fresh anymore
everybody knows who it is and they know
who we are you know it's not like their
careers have gone downhill no no no not
by any means but they're definitely not
as strong reputable as they used to be
you know then soar has had successful
movies still like not the museum flicks
and stuff
Owen Wilson has a hit here and there
well as well Farrell and Kristen wings
beat you Kristen Wiig yeah then I like
seen Benedict Cumberbatch's cameo well
yeah it seems like there will be a lot
of fun cameos I mean it seems like there
will be a lot of good surprises and
Easter eggs and things I do like the
general idea that they're going hog-wild
with the story and just being like
someone's killing everybody with your
signature look we got to make this like
an espionage movie you know cuz if the
first one had elements of that what I
like about the cameos that kind of
bother me with the first one was there
were so many cameos but I felt most of
them weren't taken advantage of like
used for any comedic bits like they
hired actor to be in there they're like
Zoolander is great and that's all they
do
I mean I didn't I didn't mind that
either it wasn't about those cameo it
wasn't like an Austin Powers movie but I
liked seeing that kind of Austin pair of
powers element here like with Justin
Bieber there Benedict Cumberbatch you
know you got Penelope Cruz in the role
you got a lot of like celebrities here
in this film but they all seem to be
doing something kind of funny yeah you
know and did Justin Bieber bit I'm a fan
of Bieber like I'm not saying that to be
cool I'm just not a fan of you I mean
for me it's just like I'm I don't have a
lot of feelings about him either would
yeah exactly seeing him like do
something like that kind of made me like
him a little bit just from the trailer
you know I mean there was a period of
time before he went crazy a little bit
there where he did some videos for Funny
or Die that I thought were fun yeah I've
seen him do something him do a bit with
Zach Galifianakis too like yeah he I
think the guy has a cool sense of humor
um he can
I like seeing Will Ferrell I was like
[ __ ] huge abut it's so obviously fake
there looks like some really [ __ ]
funny moments in this in this film one
to give the benefit of the doubt a lot
of the stuff in this trailer stuff that
would probably be better with a whole
movie around it like a silly comedy like
this and a comedy
got dumb people like it's gonna look
even dumber in the trailer I feel a lot
of time we don't really get comedies
nowadays like that was more for like 90s
early 2000s of like stupid comedies you
not like they're bad stupid but the
characters are not the smartest well we
don't live in the same time either like
the time of the of the dumb hyper
privileged model yeah this kind of come
apart now and we have like more aware
models and things like that and you know
everything is more accessible so it's
different they might need to use
Instagram in this story I'm sure they
will I'm sure we will see that it will
be topical by the way follow us on
Instagram because hey my representation
has advised me to get more followers
there so is that true story it's true
story Kyle Kyle handsome okay
my manager look him up kind of has no
real credits yet but he's getting there
anyway guys thanks for tuning in to the
channel listen I got an idea if you're
new to the channel you can subscribe by
clicking this button and become a reject
today
mm-hmm are you having not every time I
say easier extras episode become a
reject sounds like I'm trying to like
come up with a catchphrase for this
raises to Jerry and a cast stubs or
playlist host about said jer-bear on
this Chanel
Kevin make me Kevin mei-mei if it's Mei
like the dot is so small hey Ryan you're
very amazing and hilarious keep up the
good work my man one day I would love to
move down to LA to meet you and those
beautiful ladies have a like a shout out
thanks bro Kevin well Kevin listen word
of advice if you want to meet people
like a certain group of people in LA you
don't have to move here you can visit to
permanently change your whole life I
sound like you're gonna move in with
Ryan yeah exactly like I might meet you
in my talk we might have a drink smoke a
little weed sort some coke shoot some
hair whatever right now if you just want
to visit sure we can still do all those
things but you don't have to live here
that might make me uncomfortable if you
lived here in California just to meet me
and the girls and Jerry hey he didn't
mention me yeah oh I'm off the hook no
it's okay I just got sad no one made me
it's fine just got sad here's what I
gotta say before I was identifying
subscribers as looking like a serial
killer or not looking like a serial
killer now I'm gonna start going with
this person is gay or straight no yeah
okay profile people Kevin may he's got
the angles I mean this can easily come
on Rose you know what I think I think
you're gonna go for gay and I'm gonna go
for straight on this one why straight
because he's making bedroom eyes he's
got a leather jacket and he looks kind
of you know like like a pop sensation
you have just described a cliche version
of an LA gay guy I don't know though I
have one photograph to go I'm playing
this heinous game with you